but then Jake Paul said I don't roll
with States I don't get a girlfriend I'd
love to knock his ass out he said
something like that but then he said but
what I do support is you know free
speech and his brother said something
else his brother said you know the [ __ ]
that Andrew Tate says will have a ripple
effect much more dangerous than you can
imagine because his narrative is truly
hateful his rhetoric has extreme
negative energy in it and it will affect
impressionable young people that won't
show for yours from now and it's
dangerous now this is what he says right
Logan Paul you're saying but but I want
to say this before you comment on it and
then Junior supported you Tucker
supported you I think the guys that like
debate and comedians people who
appreciate humor even just look at like
the smartest people and the people that
support Tate it's like it's all G's and
like cool intelligent people that you
want to be like all the people that I
aspire to be all have similar ideologies
and they don't think like left lunacy
they agree with Andrew day and they
listen they listen for for like for
logic not just what the media is telling
them to think yeah quick story back when
I first started my entrepreneurial
journey I joined like a Forex pyramid
scheme the thing that like Snapped my
brain out of it was this guy always
Marco's video exposing them he made like
30 minute long documentaries exposing
them and so that dude saved like
thousands of people from from continuing
to spend hundreds of hundreds of dollars
a month and then this like this last
week he posted how he like doesn't think
Andrew Tate's that bad because someone
asked him what his thoughts are he's
like yeah I think he he says a lot of
like good stuff and then all of those
same people that he saved are like oh
how could you think that bro unfollowed
like these people just like to think
with the mob they don't want a thing for
themselves no you know there's a very
clear correlation it's it's crazy all
this stuff you're saying is funny as
hell you could be a comedian if you
wanted to but a person has to really pay
are you bored to the comedy you know
some some comments wrong with it some
cannot run with it when you hear the
people that support and don't support
you how do you process that so first
things first want to get very very clear
that Logan Paul is absolutely not really
a tool of the Matrix he's a fault and
sold individual with no soul he doesn't
stand up for anything and he doesn't
mean anything he says he gets pieces of
paper from Susan or whoever else telling
him what he's allowed to say on his
channel to retain you believe that 100
not only do I believe that he's proved
himself he will flip-flop on any issue
he can be bought and sold the dude's a
[ __ ] Logan Paul is a [ __ ] and I will
say that here publicly if anyone wants
to I'll fight him for free the guy's an
idiot no money needed Logan Paul doesn't
believe any of the things he says Logan
Paul is a man if you ever were
unfortunate enough to consume his
content I get sent clips of it all the
time by people mocking him as soon as
something comes out whether Harry Styles
wearing a dress whether it's uh little
Naz twerking on the devil whether it's
this he just sits there and goes yeah
this is great yeah this is great he is a
talking piece he is the mouthpiece for
the agenda the people who've come along
people who are trying to force a
narrative and they said look we need to
have some degree of control over the
exact demographic that Tate has control
over we're going to use Logan Paul and
attempt to use him all right and he sits
there and just purports the [ __ ]
points of view that the whole Hollywood
establishment want him to report he
doesn't believe anything he said he's
told what to say and because he was
canceled before and it emotionally
destroyed him he sat on camera crying
his eyes out like a little girl instead
of being a man about it he is so fearful
of the mob and so scared of being
canceled again he's going to sit there
and say anything he's told he doesn't
believe that [ __ ] before I was canceled
him and his boyfriend Mike did Endless
videos supporting me laughing about me
saying how funny I was tagging me on
Instagram inviting me places Etc second
I'm canceled they flip reverse it and
[ __ ] themselves because they don't want
to get canceled too they are children
that's all they are so Logan Paul's a
[ __ ] that's the first thing about
Liverpool and what's actually been
interesting about this whole
cancellation thing is it hasn't
negatively affected me in any serious
way because I've been saying on podcasts
for years I know a cancellation is
coming I knew it was coming I knew that
as I got more popular and more powerful
to a degree that it was going to come
but what it has done is it has awoken
the world to anyone who's perspicacious
enough to pay attention to learn which
individuals out here in the social media
space actually have character and belief
what they say and which are completely
bought and sold in our tools to The
Matrix the people who have decided to
stand up for me and say no this is
[ __ ] are people who have to some
degree credibility you know this is this
is people who say what they truly
believe but the people who were totally
a fan and then post cancellation [ __ ]
themselves in one age and to get a new
piece of paper to talk from that should
tell out the public out there exactly
who's controlled and whether these
people have a genuine narrative that
they're trying to what is the real
traveling part of it so so children uh
middle schoolers teenagers it is it is
normal and common for them to just
follow the crowd and think with think
with a crowd 100 little kids think it
packs but what scares me the most about
the people that are really making the
biggest difference
um and this is on all just generally
across our society it's not just
liberals or conservatives generally is
that people just are grown adults with
years decades of life experience don't
go beyond the surface that's what scares
me more than you know a 15 year old
who's crying in the street at a protest
thinking that they're making making a
difference or thinking that they're they
know what the hell is going on but what
scares me is that you know a 50 year old
woman or man who's out there just taking
in surface propaganda and not even
looking underneath the first level never
mind the second third tenth level it's
troubling indubitably let's not be those
people what the indubitably people I
love that word I used to say that as
like a joke in high school it just sound
like that that kid it's a good word it's
interesting Logan's one of them and
there's a few questions
I'm glad happened just for that alone
because it's actually very clear if you
go to Logan Paul's last podcast where
he's discussing me all of his fans and I
will talk about fans and viewers in a
minute because I think they're very
different things all of his fans which
he has none of all of his viewers are
sitting there insulting him saying bro
they're your [ __ ] [ __ ] like everyone
all of his own Watchers are calling him
names because it's so transparent and so
obvious what he's doing fans versus
viewers fans versus viewers very
different things so he doesn't have any
fans he has viewers and Susan and the
Matrix and the people in charge of
social media companies are like okay
we've set our media machine let me ask
you guys questions as professionals
let's assume
as professionals let's assume what I'm
saying is correct let's assume that the
social media companies when they banned
me set their media machine to all
release thousands of news articles at
the same time trying to convince the
world of an evil man if they had that
degree of power and influence which I
think we can all probably agree they do
don't you think they pick their number
one talking piece to the demographic
which is my fan and give him a piece of
paper and tell him what to say does that
all make sense does that make sense to
say well we told all the news to say
tapes bad and all of his fans are 18 to
25 year old men who do we have on
YouTube who will bend they recognize
that people are very impressionable so
then when they go to someone like Logan
Paul people people don't think for
themselves so then when they watch that
video they're like maybe Logan Paul is
very maybe it is a good thing that we
got rid of Tate right there's a 13 year
old girl going he's got pretty eyes I'm
gonna watch this so you talk about this
is pretty us oh that's all you mentioned
about Logan Paul I was just saying that
but I can see past the pretty eyes into
the dumb mind the 13 year old girl can't
hurray he's just like a little [ __ ] who
speaks to 18 25 year old men Logan Paul
okay Logan here's your piece of paper do
you want to get canceled again Logan no
you don't want to cancel do you no no
you were saying a call like that was
made 100 the two's a [ __ ] he he 180
from a super fan
rhetoric being dangerous in 24 hours
difference between you saying who you
think he is versus you making the
speculation that he got called by
somebody to say here's a narrative we
want you to take or else we'll silence
you well Logan is not capable of
independent thought so someone didn't
give him the narrative he didn't think
it up himself there's an empty vessel he
says what he is told to say somebody
somewhere told Logan what to say and
what stance we can argue whether it was
a social media company whether it's a
manager who was fearful right whether
whatever but somebody sat with Logan and
said look Tate's getting a lot of smoke
you were cool with him your boyfriend
Mike was cool with him he's getting a
lot of smoke right now you're gonna
[ __ ] out and he sat there and said yes
sir yes I will because he has no
character or no Integrity if it was all
the other way around let's imagine he
was getting canceled and I truly believe
you it's not fair I'd sit there on my
own platform and say this is [ __ ]
because I'm not bought Soldier guys he's
an owned individual so he's always going
to say what he is told to say he's
always going to sit on podcasts speaking
to the youth promoting Harry Styles
wearing a dress saying that it's great
that little knives twerks on the devil
in real time for our children to digest
and then say I'm dangerous to the youth
because that's what he's been told to
say Logan Paul has absolutely no
capability for independent thought he
has no characters man we watched some of
that Logan Paul uh reaction to Tate
being banned and he just kept saying
that these [ __ ] talking points he's
dangerous he's ain't but he didn't even
re he couldn't give any examples and he
couldn't explain so even his his he
calls him his girlfriend Mike turned
around and would say oh yeah you can see
all this sex trafficking information on
Tick Tock about about Tate and how bad
he is to women but again couldn't give
any even a single example specific
example never mind look beyond the
example and give some real context and
give some real thought on it so it's
just this surface conversation that has
no value to anybody's mind and we have
been trained as a society to just only
look at the surface only look at the
surface and you'll be happy don't use
your brain don't go deeper unless you
want to lose your [ __ ] mind when you
go deeper yeah
canceled in the past I don't think he
ever got canceled I think his channel
was demonetized for 90 days but they
kept all this stuff up he was never
taken fully down like you were fully
taken down they just kind of demonetized
this is for the uh this is what he did
the Japanese video where apparently he
went to a place where yeah you commit
suicide in Japan right yeah I'm not I'm
not completely familiar with the
absolute mechanics of his cancellation
all I do know is that he cried on
television repeatedly so the dude was
obviously emotionally affected by it and
is fearful of it and when someone is
scared of something that's the tool you
use to manipulate them he was scared of
being cancer because when this happened
to you you're 35 years old right you're
a grown man I know you like the joke I'm
an old man I mean you're in literally
your Prime bro right
um when that happened to him he was 23
years old right right this was five
years ago I think he's 27 now 22
whatever you've had a lot more life
experiences and been in fights literally
preferably all that versus someone who's
23
I can see where you're coming from being
like he's been groomed by this by this
virtual government these digital media
companies he needs them he needs them he
becomes a mouthpiece of them he needs
them and you're right he was younger at
the time I would like to think that
Patrick has been through a much harder
situation in his life at younger than 23
than cancellation and wasn't crying his
eyes out like a little girl so the dudes
obviously emotionally soft he needs them
and the reason he needs them is because
Logan Paul doesn't have fancy as viewers
and that's what's actually been
highlighted to me significantly since my
Banning that there's a massive
difference between those two things
Logan Paul is a person who needs the
platforms and needs the algorithms and
people will watch him but they will sit
there and most of them will call him
names but he will have views that's
different than having fans when you have
fans but me for example when I got
canceled they say where's tape where is
it I'll go anywhere he is I'll download
any app I'll uninstall the other I think
he'll take his content I mean I don't
know I would like to know the
demographics on other than he said 18 to
25 year old men watch Logan Paul what
are they their what are their viewpoints
in life and what how do they think
because would they you know maybe they
abandoned him when they when he [ __ ] on
tape you know maybe they also like Tate
I wonder if they have I hope so
[Music]